ان شاء الله
ان شاء
الحمد لله الحمد لله
وعليكم السلام
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام السلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك
حميد مجيد
اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
في العالمين انك حميد مجيد
اما بعد
الله سبحانه وتعالى tells us of the
pinnacle of reward
for the ultimate and pincle
‏If we were to look at the human being
and compare the human being worship
to that of the angels
we would find our worship compared to
the worship of the angels
is
not even comparable in its amount
or its consistency
or concentration.
ان الصحيح بروت صلى الله عليه وسلم
اطت السماء وحق لها ان تط
ما من موضع اربع اصابع
الا وفيه ملك قائم او راكع او ساجد لله
تعالى
هيد صلى الله عليه
الاطيط
هو الصوت الذي يخرج
من السرج
الذي يكون على ظهر الدابه
اذا ما حمل
الى غايته
وامتلا
خرج له صوت
يسمونه العرب الاطيط ويدل على امتلائه
ويدل على ثقل ما حمل فيه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
اطت السماء وحق لها انطan
‏and it with a lot of its toch out and
it makes this noise this of slapping of
cracking
when it is stretch to its limit
he mentions that the heavens
have beenched to
‏is
placeing
there is no area or space of fingers any
except that is occupied by angel that is
either standing or
prostra to
the prophet
ك
المعمور
طواف
another
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم كل يوم
يدخل منه 7 الف ملك
ولا يعودون الى يوم القيامه
بيتور كعبه
‏and 7000 anger
house and exit through the exit through
exit and this processes every day and no
one will have a second chance to do it
until the day of judgment because of the
sheer amount of angels that occupy the
heavens.
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وكم من ملك في السماوات
اي كثير
‏ang
these angels they not us human
being not distract
they don't have desires
that go against the desire of
the command of
so how can we poss
compare
‏if our
ang in qu
in
or in
how exive it is that would blow us out
of the we have no to
الله سبحانه وتالى
ادم عليه السلام
فسجد الملائكه كلهم اجمعون
اللهم
‏ang
عليه السلام and
they were the only two
standing up in this h
why
‏magrate
what is so special aboutam
that is
that him aside him and offspring from
the angels and of
the
اتجعل فيها من يفسد فيها ويسفك الدماء
ونحن نسبح بحمدك ونقدس لك
place
innocent therein
‏Even though we glorify you andy
ourselves for you in worship
constantly and consistently
but this is just one angle of worship
what is special about the human being
worship
the human being
has a different set of circumstances
that makes the human beings worship
‏ang
how is that the angels have free will
they do they have free will we have
free will
often you he people say the angels do
not have free will this is incorrect
there in the qu and
that tells us the angels do not have
free
‏havee will
differ between the angels and the human
beings is that angels are noted by
desire
they don't have the desire to disob الله
سبحانه وى
they don't have
they don't have that
internal
‏interle
of what
i would to do what want to do and what i
do ang don't have
they are nowed by this desire
and so we look at the animals that we
share the earth ‏with we see that the
anal byct
pure desire
and angels are the stark opposit
they do not have desire they have free
will but they have no desire that go
against the desire the commands of Allah
subhanah waala but the human being is
amalgamation of both
we
‏We know what we do
want to do
and weise above this strugle and inite
of our circstances and spite of our
desire to disobحه
we still
and our free
‏angle
and ourship may be less
and less frequent
however
it is a diamond that can only be
made
under very extreme very specific and
rigorous circumstances
‏And this is
un
this is what makes the human being
unique
and thison
the greatest act of worship that any
human being
can ever muster the prophets and
messengers and all of their followers
the greatest act of worship ‏is theحيد
of subhanah wa
that a person his heart and his
intentions
and make himself sincerely
and for
and he sincerity
only in the way that محمد صلى الله عليه
‏and
gu
this
act of worship and this is why we have
instances where people have entered
parad
by seemingly minuscule or
tiny
acts of worship
‏from these acts of come
under which circstances this obedience
of no matter how small no matter how
insant
what are the circstances
that about this act of worship
الله سبحانه وتالى
sincerity
andes
only
prop
عليه وسلم
لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله
يقول الحافظ ابن القيم رحمه الله في
نونيته
فللواحد
كن واحدا في
اعني سبيل الحق والايمان
للواحد اي لله سبحانه وتعالى للواحد كن
واحدا
يعني كن متحد
النيه مخلصا لله وحده
في واحد يعني في طريق وسبيل واحد وهو سبيل
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول اعني
فللواحد كن واحدا في واحد اعني سبيل الحق
والايمان
ابن القيم رحمه الله
نونيه
ustre
الله
sincer
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتالى
servant الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وما خلقت الجن والانس الا ليعبدونceptou
[Silence]
guidance fromالى
الله
any
other
sincerity
in the prop محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
instruct and gu
لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله
سوره الكهف فمن كان يرجو لقاء ربه فليعمل
عملا صالحا ولا يشرك بعباده ربه احدا
الله
سهف
let
ممد صلى الله عليه
لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يطهر قلوبنا وان يسلل سخيمتها نساله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان
ينفعنا بما علمنا والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول
اشهد اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على
حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
[Arabic recitation]
باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في
العالم انك
اللهم رب هذه الدعوه التامه والصلاه
مقودا الذي وعدته بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل كل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فيقول الله تعالى
في ايات
استفتح
بها سبحانه وتعالى سوره
اعتاد رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ان
يتلوها
في خير صلوات الاسبوع صلاه الفجر من يوم
الجمعه
على اصحابه صلى الله عليه وسلم
فكما جاء في السنن
ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يقرا
صباحا
وفي صلاه
الفجر من يوم الجمعه في الركعه الاولى
سوره السجده الم السجده
وفي الثانيه سوره الانسان
ويقال لها ايضا سوره الدهر
يقول سبحانه وتعالى
هل اتى على الانسان حين من الدهر لم يكن
شيئا مذكورا
انا خلقنا الانسان من نطفه امشاج
من نطفه امشاج
يعني نطف
مختلطه
من ماء الرجل وماء المراه
فجعلناه سميعا بصيرا
انا هديناه
السبيل
اما شاكرا واما كفورا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سوره الانسانر
[Silence]
صل
عليه وسلم
ابن عمر رضي الله تعالى عنه وعن ابيه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الفجر
جماعه
صلى الله عليه
صلاه الفجر
سهج
عائشه رضي الله عنها
ركعه سوره
رضي الله عنهم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سبحانه وتعالى
هل اتى على الانسان حين من الدهر لم يكن
شيئا مذ
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏as people
عليه
الله سبحانه وى need
what would happ to
being was never nothing الله would not
have
سبحانه وتعالى
هو الغني سبحانه وتعالى ونحن اليه الفقراء
الله سبحانه وتعالى tellر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يا عبادي لو ان اولكم واخركم
وانسكم وجنكم كانوا على اتقى قلب رجل منكم
ما زاد ذلك في ملك شيئا
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏my
serving
and
if all of you the first of you and the
last of you the human of you and the of
you all had the heart of the most man
among you this would notion
in
يا عبادي لو ان اولكم واخركم وانسكم وجنكم
كانوا على افجر قلب رجل منكم ما نقص ذلك
من ملك شيئا
first
of the kind of kind of all
الله سبحانه وتالى
need الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه
‏was
mind
was not
mention
was only know that was come to be
that time not yes بلى
الله سبحانه وتعالى انساز انا خلقنا
الانسان من نطفه امشاج نبتليه
سبحانه وتعالى
‏of drops
a miure of drops meaning a miure
of the secretions of the male and the
female
this miure is a prure
‏And
overes its development from the moment
of conception.
But in spite of all that precision and
in spite of all that honor that the
human being holds, don't forget your
origins, human being. You and I, we were
all once just drops,
just secretion. That's all we were.
‏And so simultaneously this verse
articulates the great of the
simultaneous articulates
of
احد التابعين وهو الاحف رحمه الله تعالى
يقول عجبت
للانسان كيف يستكبر
وقد خرج مخرج البول مرتين
كيف
being
‏takes from our twice in order to come
into existence we were all drops drops
of seual secretion from our mothers and
our fathers that were mixed to precision
by
that is incredible
it articulates that oversaw that from
the from the conception but as well no
matter
سبحانه وتالى
‏Dr.
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
not anyare
with that have much more
vision than we do much stronger hearing
than we do the
‏all
the need to all have
we have been
the greatest andous of
the
سبحانهى
we have
الله سبحانه وتالى
bless and
we have been created
not only can wea
made thoseengers
after
عليه
comm
الله سبحانه وى
‏ude your
believing that you are someh so
important that it could not be done
without you or me or anyone of us no
eons existed before the human being was
even a mention
only existing
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله
الابتلاء في لغه العرب ابتلى
من البلو
وهو الاظهار في لغه العرب الاظهار
فاذا ابتلى الله عبده اظهر حقيقته
الكامنه
ابتلاء
بلاء
الابتلاء
الله سبحانه وتعالى
انا خلقنا الانسان من نطفه امشاج
نبتلي
اي نظهر حقيقته الكامنه
امن الارواح الطيبه ام من الخبثاء
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏and bring to fruition and man his true
colors who he truly is
when a person
when you die when I die when your number
is pulled when your name comes up in the
draw
when ‏ang ofet
and min
what you die upon what i die upon in
final
you are
tr
صلى الله عليه وسلم صحيح مسلم من حديث سهل
يقول
انما
الاعمال بالخواتيم
primysically
[Silence]
diedan
speaking
‏mind
are
design
with incredible precision that is to
this
colors will come their true colors will
manifest
‏And
upon is they are. And does matter how
long a person lives or how a person life
is because what a person dies upon is
who they are.
يقول تعالى يود احدهم لو يعمر الف سنه وما
هو بمزحزحه من النار ان يعمر
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏some they could
more
if theyed
more years would not them from the
fireest
that's a person really is when he
and that's why some people have entered
parad without having even made a single
صلى الله عليه وسلم
احد
[Silence]
‏is
because
we were not created for no reason
to tell us he say
indeed we have created we himself
created the human being
‏and delicate miure
of secret from a mother and father
in order to test him and manifest his
colors and we gave him hearing and we
gave him the gift of sight
انا
شاكرا
‏and we made him hearing and seeing.
Indeed we have guided the human being
andown him the path the path of truth
the path of right and wrong
and he then chooses
to either be grateful
or ungrateful.
‏Notice the words here. He is he then
choes to be grateful
or ches to be ungrateful
either ches to be a
ches to be a disbeliever.
‏ches
ches
الله سبحانه وتالى
thanful
anderbief
as
ungratefulness
that what is the ence of belief
gratitude to
a deep
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
في ظلمات
‏over another darkness with darkness
with darkness الله سبحانه وتالىing
but us
right and wrong as soon as you are born
when you are able to process the you
have
‏innidal
[Silence]
يقول الله تعالى واذ تاذن ربكم لئن شكرتم
لازيدنكم
ولئن كفرتم
عذابي لشديد
الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز سوره ابراهيم
‏on
sent to you human being that if you
mecrease you andful
know
اقول
لي ولكم ولسائر المسلمين
فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور الرحيم.
[Silence]
الحمد لله
الحمد لله وحده والصلاه والسلام على من لا
نبي بعده
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
تاكيدا بعد تاكيد لبيان مقام التوحيد
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله وصفيه من خلقه
وخليله وامينه على وحيه الداعي الى رضوانه
صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على
ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد
اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما
باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في
العالمين انك حميد مجيد اللهم انصر
الاسلام والمسلمين اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين
اللهم اخدل الشرك والمشركين
اللهم افضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وكفر عنا سيئاتنا
وتوفنا مع الابرار
ربنا واتنا ما وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا
يوم القيامه انك لا تخلف الميعاد اللهم
اننا نسالك فعل الخيرات وترك المنكرات وحب
المساكين وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب
علينا واذا اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك
غير مفتونين اللهم اللهم اننا نسالك عيش
السعداء ومنازل الشهداء ومرافقه الانبياء
والنصر على الاعداء يا سميع الدعاء يا ذا
المن والعطاء اللهم
اننا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو امائك نواصينا
في يدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل فينا قضاؤك
نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك او
انزلته في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك او
استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك ان تجعل
القران ربيع قلوبنا ونور صدورنا وجلاء
احزاننا وذهاب همومنا اللهم علمنا منه ما
جهلنا وذكرنا منه ما نسينا وعلمنا الحكمه
منه اللهم ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين اماما
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك
ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا
ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا
ما احييتنا واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا
على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من عادانا اللهم
اسلل سخيمه قلوبنا اللهم اغسل حوبتنا
اللهم اغفر لنا وحط عنا خطايانا اللهم
اغفر لنا وحط عنا خطا يانا ربنا لا
تؤاخذنا بما فعل السفهاء منها اللهم انصر
اخواننا المجاهدين المضطه في كل مكان حيث
ما كانوا اللهم انصرهم على عدوهم واجعلهم
على عدوهم ظاهرين راغمين منصورين يا رب
العالمين اللهم امين وصل اللهم وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووا اعتدلوا
استووا ولا تختلفوا فتختلف قلوبكم
‏Do not
sure the
capacity
pleas take ackes
and them so not
ourangeighten
the peray
what together will beuded upon
الله
اكبر سبحانك اللهم وبحمدك
وتعا جدك ولا الهنا خيرون اعوذ بالله من
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
شيئا مذكورا
انا خلقنا الانسان من نطفه امشاج نبتليه
فجعلناه
سميعا
نبتليه فجعلناه
سميعا بصيرا
انا هديناه السبيل اما شاكرا
واما كفورا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
انا
اعتدنا للكافرين
سلاسل واغلا
وسعيرا
ان الابرار يشربون من كاس كان مزاجها
كافورا
عينا يشرب بها عباد الله يفجرونها
تفجيرا
يوفون بالنذر ويخافون يوما كان شره
مستطيرا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
السلام عليك
ورحمه وبركاته
السلام علينا وعلى عباد
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر الله
اللهم انت السلام عليك السلام
عليكم
first
இableம்
[Silence]
‏any
place that place the will be dr and the
will be theet side so the paring l you
canly go inside that area the space
এন্ডমড এড মাচ পসিবল
ইউথ হালাকা টুনাইট ইনশাআল্লাহ আফটার এশা
প্লিজ ট সন্ডে সকল ইলুংফর
আব চার সো প্লিজ কন্টাক্ট ইমাম হাসান
ইনশ্লাভ
ইউ মোডেল
সন্ডে সকল লুকিংফ আরাবিক চার
প্লিজ ডট
‏other
pleas
pleas make
all
প্রজামলাম
السلام عليكم